let's try another surface integral and
the surface that we're going to care
about s
is this shape the outside of this shape
right over here and you can see we can
kind of decompose it into three separate
surfaces the first surface is its base
which is really the filled in unit
circle down here
the second surface which we have in blue
is you can kind of view it as the side
of it you can view it as it's kind of
like the side of a cylinder but the
cylinder has been cut by a plane up here
and the plane that cuts it the plane
that cuts it is the plane z is equal to
one minus x and obviously the plane
itself goes well beyond the shape but
where that plane cuts where that plane
cuts the cylinder kind of defines this
shape so the blue surface is above the
boundary of the unit circle and below
the plane and then the third surface is
the subset of the plane of that purple
plane of z equals one minus x that
overlaps that kind of forms the top of
this cylinder and so we can rewrite this
surface integral we can rewrite this
surface integral as the sum as the sum
of three surface integrals it's the
surface integral of z
over s1
z
over s1 plus the surface integral of z
over s2
s2
plus the surface integral of z
over
s3 over s3 and we can just tackle each
of these independently so let's start
with surface one and you might
immediately want to start parameterizing
things and all the rest but there's
actually a very fast way to handle this
surface integral especially because
we're taking the surface integral of z
what value does d so what value does z
take on throughout this surface
throughout this filled in throughout
this filled in unit circle right over
here well that surface is on the x y
plane when we're on the x y plane z is
equal to zero so for this entire surface
z is going to be equal to zero you
integrate you're essentially integrating
zero zero times ds is just going to be
zero so this whole thing is going to
evaluate to zero
so that's about as simple as evaluating
a surface integral can get but it's
always important to at least keep a
lookout for things like that and it'll
keep you from kind of going down this
you know wild goose tape that wouldn't
be a wild goose chase you would
eventually get the answer anyway but you
wouldn't you don't have to waste so much
time in parameterizing things and all
the rest now let's tackle the other two
surfaces and we'll focus on surface
we'll focus on surface 2. so the x and y
values the valid x and y values are the
x and y values along the unit circle
right over here so we can really
parameterize it the way that we would
parameterize a traditional unit circle
so we could set we could set x is equal
to
let's set it and our radius is 1. so x
is equal to cosine of i'll use the
parameter u
is equal to x is equal to cosine of u
and then let's say y is equal to sine
sine of u and then u is the angle is the
angle between the positive x-axis and
wherever we are essentially on that unit
circle so that right over there that
angle right over there is u and so this
would give us for u
so as long as u is between 0
and 2 pi that we're essentially going
around this unit circle so those are all
the possible x and y values that we can
take on
and then the z value is what takes us up
above that boundary and gets it
someplace along the surface but this is
interesting because the z value it can
take on obviously a bunch of different
values but it always has to be below
this plane right over here so for this z
value i'm going to introduce a new
parameter let's call z
v that's the second parameter and v is
going to be it's definitely going to be
greater than 0 z z and v they're the
same thing they're always going to be
positive so they're definitely going to
be greater than or equal to zero but
it's not less than or equal to some
constant thing this has kind of a
variable roof on it and so it's always
going to be less than or equal to
this
it's always going to be less than or
equal to this plane right over here and
so we could say is less is less than or
equal to 1 minus x i mean we could have
said so we know that z
is less than or equal to 1 minus x but
if we use the new parameters v is z and
1 minus x is the same thing as 1 minus
cosine u
minus
cosine u and so now we have our
parameterization we are ready to
actually evaluate the surface integral
and to do that first let's do the cross
product we want to figure out what d s
is and we have to take the magnitude of
the cross product of the partial of our
parameterization with respect to u
crossed with the partial with respect to
the actually let me just write all this
stuff down instead of trying to do
shortcuts so d s
d s and this is all let me do it in blue
and still for because we're talking
about surface two d s is going to be
equal to the magnitude of the cross
product of our parameterization with the
partial of our parametrization with
respect to u crossed with our partial of
our parameterization with respect to v
d u
dv so let's write the partial of our
parameterization with respect to u and
you might say hey where's our
parameterization well it's right over
here i just didn't write it in the
traditional ijk form but i can i could
write
r
is equal to maybe i call it r2 because
we're talking about surface 2 r2 i
shouldn't use that orange color because
i use that for surface 1. i'll use that
in a still a bluish color so r
for surface 2 is equal to
is equal to cosine of u i
plus the sine
of u
j
plus
plus v
k and this is the range that the u's and
the v's can take on if i want to take
the partial of r with respect to u i
would get let's see the derivative of
cosine u with respect to u is negative
sine
u i
derivative of sine of u with respect to
u is plus cosine
u j and the derivative of v with respect
to u is just 0. so that's our partial
with respect to u our partial reducing a
different color just for the
just for the sake of it our partial with
respect to
our partial with respect to v is equal
to well this is going to be 0 this is
going to be 0 and we're just going to
have 1k so it's just going to be equal
to k and so now we're ready to at least
evaluate this cross product
so we'll evaluate the cross product and
we'll take the magnitude of that so just
this part
so just the cross product
the inside of that before we take the
magnitude
so copy and
paste so just that is going to be equal
to
is going to be equal to
the determinant the 3 by 3 determinant
let me write my components i
j
k
and then for r sub u we have this our i
component is negative sine of u
negative sine of u
our j component is cosine of u
cosine of u it has no k component so
we'll put a zero right there and then r
sub v no i component no j component and
it has one for its k coefficient and so
we can just evaluate this and so first
we think about
the i component well we ignore that
column that rho is going to be cosine of
u
minus 0 so it's going to be cosine
of u i
and then we'll have minus j times ignore
column ignore rho negative sine of u
times 1 minus 0. so it's negative j
times negative sine of u so it's just
going to be plus
sine
of u
j and then for the k
we have this times 0 minus this times 0.
so we're just going to have 0. so this
is the cross product and if we want to
take the magnitude of this
if we just take the magnitude of this
so now we're ready to take the magnitude
of this it's going to be equal to
the magnitude of this is going to be
equal to the square root
of cosine of u squared cosine of u
squared plus sine of u squared
sine of u squared there is no k
component and from the unit circle this
is the most basic trig identity this is
just going to be equal to one
and so we have this part right over here
just simplifies to 1
which is nice and ds simplifies to du dv
for at least this surface and so now we
are ready to attempt to evaluate the
integral but i'm almost running out of
time so i will do that in the next video